So we know that lots of people are irresponsible.
There are lots of ignorant people.
There's lots of people who don't really care
about how their actions affect others.
There are people who just get in over their
heads in different ways.
We know all that.
Which is why sometimes we need government
officials to step in.
I mentioned earlier in the show, in the wake
of this entire pandemic, the libertarians
are being pretty damn quiet.
And most people, by and large, understand
that the government does have a pretty significant
role to play here.
And one of the places where the government
has a role to play and quickly and we're depending
on a Republican governor to play that role
is the beaches of Florida.
Much of the country, especially blue states,
are taking social distancing seriously.
Florida beaches have mostly stayed open and
some have closed early.
But tons of spring breakers have just been
continuing to party and likely a symptomatically
spread the disease.
Check out this video of students who were
interviewed and who not only don't care about
the virus, they are annoyed that the virus
is affecting their partying and putting a
damper on their buzz, so to speak.
This video's from CBS.
You'll also see this kind of.
I don't know if this is related, but a lot
of these people who are being interviewed
by CBS, CBS.
Their faces are chafed.
They seem to be covered in bruises and sunburns
and their faces seem swollen in some cases.
I don't know why.
I don't know if it's.
They don't understand sunscreen or what's
going on.
Not sure if there's some connection between
their irresponsible behavior and the fact
that they seem very, very beaten up.
But let's take a look at the video and the
interviews.
Tiger Corona.
I get Corona a day to day.
I'm not going to let it stop me from partying.
Either way, we go away for Miami spring break
for a while.
But too much about this trip up to three months.
I was out having a good time.
Whatever happens, happens.
It's messing up with my spring break.
What is there to do here other than go to
the bars or the beach closing all of that?
Well, I think they're blowing it way out of
proportion.
I think it's doing quite some out on his back.
We need a refund.
This virus ain't as serious as Syria is.
More serious things out there like hunger
and poverty.
We need to address that.
I mean, we've had this a long time ago and
it was going to happen.
And like we're just trying to find one.
Yes, I'm ganapati.
So it's kind of disappointing, but we're just
making the most of it.
We met these other people and I let these
guys hanging out with them.
And I'm not John everything.
I mean, it sucks, but we're gonna make the
best of it.
Know, it sucks.
And I'm from New Orleans, so this really sucks.
However, we're going to enjoy ourselves.
We haven't dayparts outing my birthday, St.
Patrick's Day.
We're just trying to roll with the boy.
We're just live in for the moment.
Where does it go in for?
We're just gonna do what happens when it happens,
when stuff closes.
We're gonna do when it closes.
But besides that, we're just trying to have
the best ship we can.
This is one of the most morally depraved elements
of all of this, because it's very easy for
us to say, you know what?
They don't want to.
They want to be out there spreading and potentially
getting the virus.
Let them die if they want to be this stupid.
But that's not how the virus works.
Statistically, they will actually be fine.
Although we are seeing particularly because
of medical systems, the health care systems
being overwhelmed, that some people are not
even young people are not doing well, but
they are going to infect people who are not
going to be fine.
And this is why we need Florida's Republican
governor, not a great guy, not a great governor,
not someone we really have have been able
to count on to do the right thing.
Ron DeSantis, he's got to shut down the beaches
and his initial order on bars was very weak.
I think now he finally does seem to be shutting
down bars in Miami and Miami Beach.
So this is the problem with the initial spread
of disinformation.
Trump and Fox News over the last three, four
days have changed their tune.
They're taking the virus seriously.
But the problem is that once the disinformation
starts to spread, calling it a hoax, calling
it no big deal, saying we're not going to
have cases.
It's like a flu, whatever.
Once they get that out, it's very hard to
then change people's minds and get them to
act and realize that those initial proclamations
were very, very wrong.
Some of them won't even hear that Trump and
Fox News have now changed their tune and are
acknowledging this is serious because they're
down there partying on the beach and going
to bars.
I was scheduled to go to Miami Beach in six
days.
Obviously, I'm not going.
But if I did decide to go and I decided to
push through and just go there, I would feel
like a terrible, terrible person.
My moral framework would not let me feel okay,
knowing that even if I was statistically likely
to be fine that I was putting people at risk
by being there, I wouldn't be able to enjoy
myself.
Apparently that does not affect these these
people in the same way.
And that doesn't really.
Higher confidence in in our ability to fight
this thing properly.
The problem here is that we're depending on
everybody to do their part and it impacts
everybody, not just them.
That's the unfortunate reality.
So we need them to take it seriously.
Of course, the Trump administration response
has been atrocious.
Of course, we're woefully unprepared as a
country and as a planet for this.
But on top of it, we have people like these
kids who are making the problem worse.
There's a long incubation period for this
disease during which you are ah, you have
it, but you're not showing symptoms.
There is a high contagion rate.
All of these kids could infect people for
the next seven days and in a week find out
that they themselves are sick.
And then the people they infected before they
were symptomatic would have another few days
before they realized they had it.
And they're walking around spreading it as
well.
And before you know it, this is how it spreads
and this is how you get an R not value that
is somewhere between, you know, it looks like
between one and a half and four and a half.
Probably in reality between something like
1.8 and 3 with with coronavirus.
So I wish we could just say, screw them.
It's only it's they are only endangering themselves.
Let them do whatever they want.
That's not the case.
And that's why we all have to be responsible
at this point.